ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนคนนี้
ของผู้หญิงนั้นของกูเอง
โอเค
ค่ะก่อนอื่นวันนี้วันอะไรค่ะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสค่ะวันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 14 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพต
เท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565  3K ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะดีคอยต2
022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงก็ต้องตอนนี้
เวลา
17:40 สองนาทีค่ะขอ 05:42 นาทีเป็น
17:00 น
ไข่ค่ะไม่ร้อนให้สว่างสบายๆราคาการป่าหิว
นิดนี่
รู้หญิง
อะไรคะมีนักเรียนกี่คน
หอเรามีนักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8
9  10  11
11 คนค่ะคนนะคะ
โอเควันวันคลิปนี้เราจะทำอะไรไปไหนนี่เรา
มีทำถามอีกแล้วค่ะคุณเอ๋
เมื่อสองคนชอบถาม
ใต้ถามนะเรียน
ถามครูเอ๋ไหม
ขาย
ถามครูเอ๋ด้วยถามนักเรียนด้วยถามทุกคนใช้
ค่า
ใครดูฟังครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋สอนก็ถามนัก
เรียน
ตายค่ะถามอะไรคะเอ้า 3 ว่านัดโพสต์คลิป
ที่แล้วเนี่ยนักเรียนเนี่ยรู้จักรถค่ะ
แล้วห่าก็จะถามนักเรียน
นักเรียนเนี่ยอยู่ที่บ้านนี้บ้านครูเอก
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋อยู่ที่บ้านอ่าแล้วก็ครูเอ๋
เนี่ยหลังจากที่บ้านไปทำงานค่ะอยากไปทำ
งานไปออฟฟิศค่ะครูเอ๋ไปยังไงโหโอเคนะคะมี
เวลาหนึ่งชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะ
ทำไม 1 ชั่วโมง
คู๋พูดนาน
กล้วยเอาสั้นๆต่างๆกันสั้นๆนะคะฟันๆ 30
นาทีโอเคมั๊ย
ได้ค่ะเลยนะครูเอขอ Share  screen ได้ไหม
คะได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
เดี๋ยวดูก่อนโอเคเดี๋ยวคุยแช่ตะกี้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงถ้า
โอเคครูเอ๋กำลัง Share  screen ออกมาแล้ว
เห็นใช่ไหมคะเห็นค่ะเอกไปมีปากกานะคุย
ช่องอะไรมีเค้าผู้หญิงขีดก่อนนะครับไม่
แน่ใจว่ามันจะเห็นถึงแค่ไหนแต่ผู้หญิง
เห็นเท่านี่ที่ไหนคะคุยรออยู่เส้นสี
น้ำเงิน
โอเคพูดอย่างนี้กูหญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยว่าอัน
นี้เป็นเป็นแบบนี้แล้วกันเป็น
เป็นบ้านเนาะค่ะบ้านคุยเปลี่ยนสีก่อนรึ
ได้ค่ะคุณจะเปลี่ยนสีอะไรสีดำอ่ะ R คู่
เอ๋ไม่ได้อยู่บ้านครูเอ๋อยู่
กินอะไรคอนโด
ขอครูเอ๋อยู่ที่คอนโด
อายอยู่ที่คอนโดนะคะ
เวลาครูเอ๋จะไปทำงาน
สถานเห็นนอนอย่าตื่น
อาบน้ำ
แปรงฟัน
เสร็จแล้วใส่เสื้อใส่กระโปรงค่ะมิมีผม
ก่อนใช่ไหมไม่เป็นไรไม่มี
หนังยางทำอะไรคะหนังยางรัดผมขอครูเอ๋เอา
หนังยางเนี่ยรัดผมรักผมค่ะ
ต้องต้องรัดผมก่อนนะ
ไม่ได้โอ๊ยต้องรับผมเหรอคะทำไม
รัดผมก่อน 5 จุดเดี๋ยวครูหญิงจะรู้
ว่าทำไมครูเอ๋รักขมใช่คู๋รักผมเม็ดรัฐยัง
ไงอ่ะรักผมเหมือนครูหญิงไหมไม่ได้กูอีก
รัฐแล้วก็ม้วนๆ
ขอขอขอม้วนด้วยเฮ้ย
รู๋ร้อนหรอม้วนผม
ร้อนนิดหน่อย
บางทีครูเอกก็ถัดเปียก่อน
ครับเปียยังไงนี่ไงครูเอกก็เอามาแล้วก็
ถักเปียค่ะ
ซึ่งโอ๋
ครูเอ๋ทำกำลังถักเปียใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้ไอค่ะ
ถักเปียอ่ะโอเคถักเปียเร็วมากเก่งมากต้อง
เร็วๆไปทำงานไปทำงานไปทำงานไปทำงานเร็วๆ
เพราะว่า
เมื่อก่อนเนาะเมื่อก่อนอ่ะอาทิตย์ที่ทำ
งานอันนี้ที่ทำงานนะคะไกลเลย
มาไกลแล้วก็ทำงาน
9:00 นครูเอ๋ทำงานตั้งแต่ 9:00 นนแต่คู
เอนนอนแล้วก็ตื่นเนี่ยคืนกี่โมงคะครูเอ๋
18:00 น
แล้วอาบน้ำแปรงฟัน
เขียนคิ้วทาปากมั้ยถ้า
ไม่มีเวลา
ออโต้เสื้อใส่กับรองถักเปียเร็วๆเร็วๆ
แล้วยังทำอาหารกุ๊กกู f ตื่น 6 โมงทำหาย
ก็กูเอกแต่งงานแล้วอ๋อ
อันนี้ฟ้ามีพระเอกก็ต้องทำอาหารสามีแล้ว
อ่ะถ้าไม่มีเวลา
เขียนคิ้วทางเปล่าไม่มีเวลาอาหารสามี
เสร็จเอกก็ต้องวิ่งลงชั้น 5 ลงๆๆข้างล่าง
ค่ะแล้วทำอะไรต่อนางๆก็มีรถรถอะไรคะรถอ๋อ
เหมือนเหมือนๆตุ๊ก
รถตุ๊กๆจุ๊บๆกับผู้หญิงมีไหมกูเอ๋ไอ้นัก
แสดรถตุ๊กๆแป๊บนึงนะคะ
นี่อะรถตุ๊กตุ๊กรถตุ๊กๆนะคะคู่เอกรถตุ๊ก
ตุ๊ก
รถตุ๊กๆเลยค่ะอ๋อโอเคโอเคอะไรไหมคะโอเค
อ๋อครูเอวิ่งลงมาแต่ฉัน 5 แล้วก็ลงลงๆได้
รถตุ๊กตุ๊กจที่คอนโดมีรถตุ๊กๆเนาะอ่ะมี
ล้อ
กติ๊ก
กูเอกก็นั่งที่นี่
ปากซอยปากซอย
ปากซอยอะไรปากซอยแล้วตรงนี้มีซอยใช่ไหมคะ
มีซอย
รถตุ๊กๆก็ออกมาสีแดงดีกว่ากาก
รถตุ๊กๆก็ออกมาที่นี่ออกมาที่นี่ออกมาที่
นี่ตอนนี้เป็นถนน
ถนนใหญ่ค่ะ
รถตุ๊กๆก็จะออกมาตรงๆดิ
น้องนี้เรียกอยู่ซอยเหรอคะ I ค่ะปากซอย
แล้วก็จอด
ลงแล้วก็วิ่ง
วิ่งไปไหน
โอ้วตรงนี้อ่าที่ปากซอยเนี่ยตรงนี้มี
รถไฟฟ้า
BTS หมู
แปลว่ามี
มีอะไรคะมีบันไดใช่ไหมพรุ่งนี้มีบันได
งั้นใดขึ้นรถไฟฟ้าเหรอคะให้บันไดแล้วก็
ขึ้นไป
ไปแล้วกูเอกต้องดู
ดูอะไร
ถ้าที่นี่มีคน
คนคน
คน
ทำไมคนมากๆมีคนมากๆ B  a  f เวลา
18:30 นค่ะ
ถึง
8:30 น
มันไม่เห็นค่ะตรงนั้นโอเคขอโทษค่ะ
คุยลบกันนะคะคนรายการครึ่ง
ถึง
8:30 นป่าวโห
คนบนรถไฟฟ้ามากงูแล้วเห็นที่มันใดมีคนคนๆ
คร๊ทำยังไงอ่ะไปไม่ได้กันลงมา
แล้วก็ดูที่ถนน
you อะไรที่ถนน
ดูว่ารถติดไหมผมขอ
ถ้ามีรถติดติดรถ
อันนี้เนี้ยรถนะคะอ่ะอ่ะกูให้รถเป็นสีแดง
อ่ะรส
รสสีม่วงอ่ะอ้า
รสสีม่วงกับสีแดง
รถติดนะคะไม่ได้ชนนะคะ
มีรถมีรถมีรถมีรถมีรถมากๆรถใกล้ๆกันรถไป
ไม่ได้รถติดคู่เอกก็หาแท็กซี่
มองแพ็คดีมั้ยไม่ได้รถติดไง
นะครับตรงนี้
มีรถติด
อ่ะรถติด
รถติดอ่ะ
[เพลง]
แต่รถติดมากๆ
ไม่รู้ x แท็กซี่ไม่ได้
BTS รถไฟฟ้าไม่ได้รถเมล์รถเมล์อีก
ไม่ได้
โอเคมอเตอร์ไซค์
รู้เองเรียกมอเตอร์ไซค์เหรอคะให้
มอเตอร์ไซค์แท็กซี่
ประเทศไทยมีมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์
ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมผมขอ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยถักเปียแล้วก็ม้วนผม
เพราะว่าต้องนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์จากที่บ้าน
ไปไอ้
ออฟฟิศมือนปีหน้าก็นั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์นะคะ
แตๆถ้าออกเดินออกมานะคะอ่ะไม่มีรถติดค่ะ
อ๋อไม่มีรถติด
ไม่มีรถติด
อ่ะแท็กซี่รถเมล์โอเค
รถเมล์
รถเมล์โอเค
แต่มีหลายไปอีกอะไรอีกคะแต่
ๆๆโอเคนะข้าข้าออกมา
บีทีเอส you  BTS
คนนิดหน่อยยิ่งครูเอ๋
ดีใจอะไรขึ้น
ค่า
บีทีเอสเร็วเร็วๆๆ
BTS
ที่ทำงานออฟฟิศเลยไม่ใช่
สถานีต่อไป
สยามค่ะ next  station
Siam  Siam
ลบตรงนี้นะคะผู้หญิงค่ะได้เค้าคู๋
ขึ้นบีทีเอสนั่ง BTS จาก
Condominium บ้าน
งู
Siam อันนี้ BTS
สถานีสยามค่ะออฟฟิศอยู่ที่นี่
เขาแล้วจากสยาม Siam เนี่ยเอารถไปออฟฟิศ
oem ไปยังไง
ตรงนี้เนี่ยอะไรคะมีมีซอยมีถนนถนนตัดถนน
ต้องนี้ก็มีถนนอะไรคะเมื่อมี 2 ถนนแล้วก็
มาที่นี่
มาที่ออฟฟิศครูเอ๋ที่ทำงานที่ทำงานอ่ะพระ
เอกก็ต้องดูเวลา
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมต้องดูเวลาคะถ้ากูเอ๋ถึง Siam
7:00 นครึ่งน
หน้าไปทางไหน
Ra  A  B
A  O  K  B โอเคจะเดิน
ขอเดินจาก BTS
สอบถามไปที่ทำงานให้เดินมาที่นี่ค่ะอย่า
ที่นี่โอเคเดิน
วันนี้มีเวลามากๆมายแต่ถ้ากูเองจริงสยาม
กี่โมงคะ
8:20 นนค
รูเอทำงาน 9:00 น
9:00 น 11 ครู f ไปยังไงอ่ะถึง Siam
8:20 นมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์ of ครับเปียสำหรับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์
ผักเปียสำหรับมอเตอร์ไซค์ถ้าไม่ถักเปีย
เวลายังไงมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหมเรานั่งมาไปพบ
ที่นี่ก่อนอ่ะอ่าเนี่ยครูเอ๋เอ๋นั่ง
มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ใส่แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ๆ
หลายอ่าให้นักเรียนดู
ดูไหมนี่ค่ะมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่ครูเอ๋นั่งมี
ผู้ชายมีคนขับแล้วก็มีมอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วก็
ครูเอ๋นั่งผมมันจะพันอย่างนั้นนักเรียน
พันพันแล้วก็เวลา
หวีโอ๊ยเจ็บอา
เหนี่ไงครูเอ๋ว่าให้ไม่ใช่เห
รอปล่อยผมแบบผู้หญิงคนนี้ไม่ได้ได้ค่ะเอ๋
ทำแบบนี้เลย
เก็บผลตอน 2
บัญชีก็ม้วนม้วน
อันนี้โอเคแล้วก็มอเตอร์มอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่ค
ไป
ขี่เร็วๆใช่ไหมครับผม
หิวผมปลิว
มอเตอร์ไซค์มีเวลานิดหน่อยมอเตอร์ไซค์บ่
ครับแล้วก็
ที่ทำงานถึงที่ทำงานให้
พันเก้าโมงไหมคะ
ทันค่ะกูเอกก็ถึงที่ทำงานให้เงินวิ่งไป
ออฟฟิศ 3 เหนื่อยมาก
a ถึงที่ทำงาน
08:00 น
20  40 นาที
ร้าน
08:25 น
มอเตอร์ไซค์ 5 ประมาณ 5 นาที 9 จอง 8 โมง
20 นาทีถึงออฟฟิศ
อากง 25 หน้าประมาณ 8 โมง 25 นาทีน
[เพลง]
หาแป้ง
โอเคค่ะอ๋อ
ครูเอ๋ไปที่ทำงานหัวครูเอ๋มีไปที่ทำงาน
จากคอนโดมิเนียมรถตุ๊กตุ๊ก 5
BTS ค่ะมอเตอร์ไซค์
บางบางทีเดินนะคะเกินบางทีมบ้านก็
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปเลยโอ้โหครูเอ๋แล้ว
จากบ้านไปถึงออฟฟิศที่ทำงานครูเอ๋ใช้เวลา
เท่าไหร่คะประมาณเท่าเองนั่ง BTS ไป
BTS  Web  4
BTS
บ้านครูเอ๋มาถึงที่นี่
ประมาณเดี๋ยวนัดตรงนั้น 15  20 นาที
จาก BTS ที่บ้านครูเอ๋ถึง BTS สยาม 20
นาทียี่สิบนาที
ค่ะจากสยามมา
ออฟฟิศ R เอ่อถ้าเดินเดินๆก็ครึ่งชั่วโมง
มากเกาะ
30 นาทีรู้เดินช้าๆ
นักเรียนนักเรียนนะ
เดินจาก BTS สยามมาออฟฟิศครูเอ๋ AE นาที
10 นาที
ร์ดแม่ครูโอ๋เดินครึ่งชั่วโมงหรือว่า 30
นาทีก็ดูเองกี่นาทีครูหญิงเดินน่าจะ
ประมาณ
20 นาที
ครูเอ๋ 30 น่ะ
ครูหญิงเดินกับครูเอ๋
เพราะ 30 นาทีค่ะ 40 นาทีค่ะทำไมเดินแล้ว
ก็ดูนักอยู่สะดึก
ถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูป 40 นาทีคุยๆๆ
โอ้วครูเอก็ใช้เวลาจากบ้าน
มาออฟฟิศประมาณทั้งหมดเนี่ยประมาณอ่า
40-50 นาทีดูหนัง
40-50 นาทีนะคะก็มอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่ถึงเนาะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ 30  30 ค่ะถ้ากูเองเนี่ย BTS
สยามแล้วก็มอเตอร์ไซค์
ประมาณ 30 นาที
ถ้าประมาณ 30 นาทีก็ถึง
ออฟฟิศงู
สบายสบายนะคะครูหญิงล่ะคะ
ครูหญิงไปออฟฟิศ
ผู้หญิงใส่ให้ออฟฟิศยังไงคะครูหญิงจาก
บ้าน
เอลิคอร์ปเตอร์ไหมคะอุ้ยผู้หญิงรวยเหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงเหมือนครูเอ๋เอ๋อยู่คอนโดมิเนียม
อ่า
แล้วก็จากคอนโดมิเนียม
จะไป BTS
BTS ครูหญิงนั่งรถตู้ค่ะครูเอ๋
ดีกว่าครูเอ๋
ตุ๊ก
แน่ค่ะครูหญิงนั่งรถตู้รถตู้
คอนโดมิเนียมโห Condominium ครูหญิงดีมาก
ครูเอ๋
สิบบาท
ไม่ฟรีหรอคะไม่ใช่ฟรีค่ะ 10 บาทตุ๊กดี
กว่าฟรี
ใช่ไหมเนี่ยเอ่อรถตู้เนี่ยสบายเย็น
10 บาทน้อ
โอเค
โอเคไม่
แล้วก็ไปเดินเด้อ
ขอเชิญประมาณ
10-15 นาที
ไกลเหมือนกันเนาะผู้หญิงเดิน 15 นาทีค่ะ
เกาะรถตู้ 10 บาทประมาณ
3-5 นาที
ถึงบุ PS ดีกว่า
ผู้หญิงออกมาไม่มีรถตู้ทำยังไงไม่มีรถตู้
ตรงนี้
มีมอเตอร์ไซค์
เบื่อเหมือน
จัดมอเตอร์ไซค์ 20 บาทครูเองมอเตอร์ไซค์
แพงแพงแต่ผู้หญิงชอบรถตู้ทวิแชร์อยู่ได้
สุด
รถตู้ดีกว่าค่ะดีกว่าสบายๆและแล้วก็ถึง
BTS
ค่ะสยาม
เหมือนครูเอ๋อ๋อเมื่อก่อนออฟฟิศที่เดียว
กันนะคะค่ะผู้หญิงแล้วจากสยามครูหญิงไป
ออฟฟิศไปยังไงคะผู้หญิงนั่งรถเมล์ค่ะครู
เอ๋
ผู้หญิงรถเมล์
เดี๋ยวคุยให้ดูรถเมล์ค่ะครูเอ๋รอดูมีห่า
น้องเมล์ครูหญิงล่างรถเมล์จากสยามผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงปิดติดรถเมล์ได้ไหมออกไอ้เมย์บอก
แล้วนักเรียนเข้าใจรถเมล์แล้ว
กินกำลังดูอันนี้ BTS ใช่ไหมคะอ่า vs มัน
ไปทางไหนอ่ะออฟฟิศหรอข้างล่างข้างล่างผู้
หญิงทั้งๆที่นี่
มัดมี 2 โน้ทออฟฟิตอยู่ตรงกลางอันนี้
ออฟฟิศอ่ะแล้วก็มีความผูกผันอ้นถนนแล้วก็
ถนนมี MBK มี MBK ตรงนี้นะคะ MBK ให้นู้น
อันนี้เอ็มบีเค
ทำให้มันไม่เป็นไรไม่เข้าใจ
แต่รถเมล์เนี่ยทุเรศรถเมล์มาไทยจริงๆ MBK
อยู่อีกฝั่งนึง
ก็ผิดอันนี้อันรีย์ดูหนังอะไรดูนะ
MBK ใช่ไหมคะโอเคโอเคผู้หญิงนั่งรถเมล์
จากตรงนี้ไม่รู้อย่างนี้นะค่ะ
โหลดแล้วก็ออฟฟิศค่ะง้อผู้หญิงนั่งรถเมล์
นะคะรถเมล์ผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวนะผู้หญิง beasts
คะแล้วก็เดินลงมาลงมาแล้วก็รอรถเมล์ไทย
ค่ะรอรถเมล์ผู้หญิงไม่เดินหรอคะไม่เดิน
ค่ะ
ร้อนง้อผู้หญิงไม่นั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์เหรอคะ
ไม่นั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ค่ะมอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่เร็ว
แล้วก็แพง 5 ส้มนี่ค่ะ 50 บาทวัน
ครูเอ๋ครูหญิงนั่งรถเมล์ 13 บาท 13 บาท
สบาย
พัดลงจากรถเมล์คุยลงจาก BTS ผู้หญิงก็
ขึ้นรถเมล์รถเมล์ก็ตรงไปแล้วก็เลี้ยวซ้าย
หรอเดี๋ยวสาวไม้อ่ะแล้วก็เลี้ยวซ้ายแล้ว
ก็จอดข้างหน้า
โน้ทออฟฟิตทรายค่ะ
13 บาท 13 บาท
ไม่แพงแล้วก็วิ่งก็ไม่วิ่งไม่วิ่งผู้หญิง
มีเวลามากๆผู้หญิงไหมทำอาหารไม่มีสามีผู้
หญิงก็เดินเดินเครื่อง
จ่ายค่ะขายนะคะ
วันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้เมื่อก่อนครูหญิงกับ
ครูเอ๋ไปออฟฟิศราคะคู่เอ๋แจงนั่งรถ BTS
เปลี่ยนเดินบางทีเปลี่ยนมอเตอร์ไซค์ราคา
บางทีไม่นั่ง BTS ไปยังไงมอเตอร์ไซค์
คอนโดมิเนียมออฟฟิศไปมอเตอร์ไซค์
360 บาทเอางู
ไปสอนเขียนชั่วโมงคะๆๆ
มอเตอร์ไซค์
360 บาทคอนโดมิเนียมพร้อมฟิตใช่ 55555
รถติด
bts
ไปไม่ได้
ก็ก็มอเตอร์ไซค์
ๆแต่เร็วๆเวลาลงจากมอเตอร์ไซค์กูเอง
โอเคไหมคะโอเค a  Quest หัวใจขาน่ะสัน
หัวใจจุ๊บๆจุ๊บๆๆๆตื่นเต้นไม่โอเคค่ะ
แต่ว่าประมาณ
10 ครั้งเท่านั้น
ถ้าแบบดูแล้วโอ้แต่รถติด
bts โคนมากๆ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้เพราะว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์จาก
บ้านไปออฟฟิศไกลจะแพงนะคะ
โอเคไปแล้วเนาะนักเรียนไปออฟฟิศยังไงนัก
เรียนบอกขับรถ
โอยขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
งู
เดินเดินๆจักรยานนะครับบางคนปั่นจักรยาน
บางคนจักรยานนะคะ
เรือไหม
หน้ามีเรือหรอครูเอ๋เอ๋พายเรือนะคะนั่ง
จากหญิงผู้หญิงนี้จะเรือแบบนี้นะคะคู๋
เรือ
โอ๊ยอันนี้ไหม
ผู้หญิงมีเรือพอดีอิอิเรือนเล็กๆผู้หญิง
อันนี้ไม่ใช่อันนี้ไม่ใช่เหรอมาเป็นเรือ
ลิ้นเร็วๆๆค่ะต่างโอเคไหมโอเคเนาะวันนี้
ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะก็รู้คู่หญิงคู่เอ๋ไป
ออฟฟิศยังไงนะคะฝากนักเรียนไปยังไง
comment บอกได้นะคะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไป
ก่อนเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ